[Music]
the last dragon tells the story of raya
who is a lone warrior living in the
world of kumandra after being separated
from her family living in a divided
world she takes it upon herself to
unify all the disparate lands of
camandra and bring the world back
together
hello everyone my name is carlos lopez
estrada i am one of the two directors of
raya and the last dragon hi everyone my
name is faan virasantan i'm the head of
story on raya in the last dragon the
scene you're about to see after the
whole action-packed scene earlier we
just wanted to single in on raya's
relationship with her dad the purpose of
the scene is to introduce us to the
world of kamandra to show us that
there's five different lands and that
they are perceived as enemy lands and
then benja very cleverly uses the soup
as a tool to explain to her that even
though the lands are separate they
shouldn't be
on the first shot we use a lot of the
technique of the frame within the frame
for this film and i was inspired from
our research trip where we go through
southeast asia a lot of the places we've
been there's a lot of the use of long
corridor and anywhere you look or take
photos there's a frame within the frame
and the top of each of these building
structures you see the principle of
using repetition in design and that is
the very principle of southeast asian
temple design that we kind of adapt and
in the next chart you'll see
a little bit of the fantasy animal to
make sure that you clock that this is
not a real world
and in this shot we want to show the
daily life in southeast asia and every
morning you go and you do something to
pay respects to the invisible world
[Music]
we decided to add this like cloth wipe
transition just to make it a little bit
snappier i think we probably saw like 10
versions of this animation just because
we like to explore things until we're
out of time and then we landed on a very
simple solution but it felt right you
know what i was just thinking fun if we
could go back and do over
i would probably add like a little bit
of a focus shift you know the background
could have been a little blurry and then
we do like a shift to find them
next time
i think we specifically liked here the
the contrast between benja and raya you
see him like walking all proper hands
behind his back and then raya comes in
just like kicking and screaming and
rolling around and it just very clearly
shows the two characters i would like to
point out that fawn was one of the key
promoters of making benja look so
attractive an adele limb can't leave her
out of that in adelaide the new york
times wrote a whole article featuring uh
benja
vegas hotness so thank you fun and adele
i'm glad you feel prepared dewdrop
because i have something important to
tell you if you ever zoom in to their
fabric pattern what we found is that in
southeast asia if there's a specific
flowers or animals that's really common
in that area it will show up in what
they wear heart is about water
and their relationship with the dragon
and if you look at ryers cape at the
bottom there's an image of raindrop even
if you look here at the handrail and the
figure that is repeated throughout it's
a water drop and there's a lot of flat
motif all apart tell me what you know
about the other lens
first tail for this little sequence
everything has outlines the colors are
rendered a lot flatter it gave us this
really interesting look that we liked
just whenever raya went into our
fantasies and you can see as we were
talking about like the land identities
if you look at the first one this is
tale it's at the very very edge of
kamandra it's an arid landscape they
live off of the land and their colors
are warm and yellow and earthy tone so
you get to see it very clearly here
fonda anything that you want to say
about talon i just want to point out how
if you ever walk the night market
anywhere in asia this is the exact vibe
you'll get i thought it would be awesome
to put durian in here even though to to
throw durian in the air and cut it like
this it's probably not that realistic
but hey
i don't know when else i will see durian
in in a disney movie durian's this
incredible fruit from the region that is
is specific for many reasons but one of
them is the the incredibly strong smell
yeah and we thought that it's important
denghai is not like yeah it smells he's
like yes
it smells good
so this is land of spine spine is up
north in the mountains fine has the fame
of being this home of warrior community
and they're formidable and they have
like a squinty face like i'm gonna
destroy you kind of look the last of of
our lands is fang
as you can tell all the geometry is
sharp they got insane looking battle
cats so we here introduce them as like
the ultimate baddie and that shows you
really sort of like one of the main
ideas in the movie which is that we we
really shouldn't be making assumptions
in people based on where they live also
there's a hidden mickey in this little
fang bit
so if you
want to
pause it somewhere in there you may or
may not find the silhouette of mickey
mouse hidden somewhere in here i'm not
going to tell you where it is because
then that defeats the purpose okay so
we're going to need some crossbows and
catapults and oh what about flaming
catapults we always have this passion to
put food in this film and i took a thai
cooking class and i remember the chef at
the time was saying that like southeast
asian cooking just about putting things
that on paper they don't go well
together like bitter salty sweet you
know all those five flavors but somehow
when they come together that is
reflective of this region lifestyle like
people coming from different places and
it's such a perfect way to to stay the
theme of the movie i was trying to
convince fawn that we should eat some
soup while we did this interview today
and
she kindly
passed on the idea
we were once unified harmoniously as one
we were thinking of this scene as our
simba and mufasa moment at the the top
of the lion king where mufasa like
states the big idea of the movie and
even though he's not around for the rest
of it like the philosophy resonates so
strongly in simba that is essentially
what drives him and this scene played
like a very similar function when i see
this shot i i'm reminded of like any
time that we talk about
mandra and harmony and togetherness they
like the use of the bokeh effects yeah
yeah
long lenses with like beautiful blurry
background and you see all the bokeh
lights just like really really dreamy
and aspirational so to wrap things up i
would say that it's also a good
opportunity to talk about our our set
extension and map painting which is you
know very nerdy animation uh terms but
so set extension is just
everything that ghosts are like beyond
what's built in this particular shot
raya and benja are obviously cg
characters that are fully
three-dimensional the the building that
they're in is also cg and fully
three-dimensional and then everything
beyond that
like the mountain range the river the
sky
is painted flatly and these are called
matte paintings and then it's all
composited together i've only been
around disney animation for a little bit
but they tell us that this scene
utilizes set extension and matte
painting techniques that have never been
done before at least in disney animation
just because the level of detail and the
scope of our world was so so huge that
there's so many map paintings
and as a button i will just say
just imagine how much cooler it would
have been if we had been eating soup
throughout this whole thing
fun
i uh
next time you're right carlos next time
we'll be eating on camera
[Music]
you